and drives episodi sirti stati la mappa
in teatri per l'evento esatto funziona
funziona
qua e sul muro la maledizione est nord
est
tieni premuto sinistra con la bussola
per contare i passi di 456 cielo peccato
subito bellissimo sono curioso di vedere
ayachi male perché sono poca vacchio che
è successo lo sparo lo squalo
oddio re fisico perché l'abbia come
farebbero la piena suo zio
prendi il virus non è vero non lo sapevo
mai da ora che non è vero che lì a chi
seconda falla la bora pirla e ti
ubriachi braga basta mai finito il suo
zio
oddio eccoli in circolo sono caduta
fermi famiglia sostenuto la nave come se
questo l'ho saltato e mi ha esaltato
sinistra oddio stavolta è che proprio
vietata in faccia come stanno vino
abbiamo invitato in faccia ecco anche
sta avvitando su una scaletta di
candidare anche schifo ma come come
facevate bastava guardare la faccia di
pietro che schifo che schifo perché
stiamo commentando vedere papà merda che
avevamo invitati facciano paura di poter
bere birra stati papà mi lavare guardate
la parte per praga mettiamo le volevo
l'area campo alcun hanno scoperto né per
pulici e archi vedo che sembri beyoncé
sono ubriachi vediamola ancora ancora
ancora ancora ancora bianco anche sta
facendo ragazzo secondo disgrazie il
titanic rea nord no perché ok guardalo
tutti i partecipanti ovvio che sono poi
madoff perfetto è un buon segno
non è un buon segno allora cosa
rimarcando capisce rimarcando la sua
porca vacca qualcuno ripari come si è
facile non così prendi il secchio
buttafuori l'acqua di prima che
prendesse il sogno si avvera ed è
bellissimo non puoi votare per fitti di
giocare una persona dai min chiama gioco
è bellissimo ma torniamo sulla grandi
partiamo da lì dobbiamo ripresa dei
minatori in tv che bello e bambini
malati liberate questa la missione noi
punta una pistola 41 madonna dai
divampare che altri nemici che distrugge
ma sei una tettona pietro ragazza una
nave davanti a noi
dopo lo manterrò il dritto davanti a
occhio che abbiamo un tesoro solo
prendiamo d'america ricaricano
ricaricate carica non è poi ha caricato
il cannone sì ma ci hanno visti anche
perché come dovresti tagliare le ignora
se in italia l'isola tagliati i nostri
stati sarà completamente pari a sinistra
di tagliare l'isola perché se li
guadagnano terreno c'è mare
avete caricato tutti i cannoni tutti che
non scaricate raga sono qua subito solo
qua subito sparati immediatamente non
può immediatamente superabile se per
adesso no
ancora ancora ancora ancora ancora
ancora ancora maledizione di avete
mancati preso no porca vacca rete
mancati sistema ancora ancora ancora
ancora ancora ancora ancora
io mi sostrato turn over rimasti fermi
poi a saltare da saltiamo li aspettiamo
gli rubiamo gliela e ancora altro nostro
arco però ma non possiamo girare
riusciamo a stare col cannone dalla rete
girano voci strane veniva qualche modo
ma c'è qualcuno ancora perché la casa
dicendo del signore però perfetto vai
dobbiamo prendere nova girate il ticino
il timone parate sparate tutti sparati
adesso
ancora bollente quella latente
prendete la priorità prendiamo tutti da
parte sopra forza una foca di quell'arte
i tesori anni ci ripensa sta fondando la
barca non riesco a fondante cc io
produco io non riesco a rendere ceo era
preso un altro rai che va da carlo
cartier ha preso un altro niente niente
nel nostro sito per de luca ha preso una
carica quindi abbiamo rovinato due
giorni di gioco e il backup le cautele
che dietro alla fine maya che i giorni
mi consolerò astronave ragazzo nemico
infiltrato la nostrana e sotto sotto
l'occhio sotto sotto sotto mi ha sparato
in faccia anche io gli ho sparato subito
sotto vi farà di subito vieni quando il
nemico cornice un nemico qua si parla di
perfetto mica serata secci ammazzava
questo qualcuno non poteva 4 controllo
aderenti preferito nessuno l'aveva visto
sì sì ce l'abbiamo tutti e due celeron
ha promesso due dietro lati del capitano
ma da ventura l'ha risolta dai noi che
c'è un bowl in mezzo all'acqua ed è
scesi insieme risultato basta
ma scusate ma una volta che veniamo i
tesori perché sapete che amiamo vive coi
auto che sono i soldi ma scusa ma se
adesso se vuoi rivenderli sia punto
dobbiamo andare lì vediamo ci sono ci
abbiamo 5 tesori sulla nave rega ma mai
vista una roba del genere abbiamo
assolutamente a consegnarli dove l'auto
ma che facciamo accendiamo le luci o le
spagnolo di tutto ma neanche presa rega
non ci posso credere sono allibito
sinistra sinistra sinistra l'ancora che
ti o regali per i valori prendiamo i
pali una testa c'è la squadra
addirittura sono veloci veloci a fa sta
roba che se salta non ci rubano tutto
mara vederci a 363 buono scusate dove si
consegnano allora si consegnano vieni e
mancano anche altre parti giudizio
guarda ok ok files sl cast
perché siamo fan celebrazioni soldi in
tre secondi
vedo ragazzi mare lo stiamo facendo per
passione o no no sto facendo per i
monaco facciamo i piloti per passione
prendiamo l'altra questo no questo non
voglio finire non prendiamo un altro dai
no non è finita scopri il ridge
heidsieck esmond quanti soldi vuoi
complicano io non ricordo male le armi
qua a di al blu ma dov'è il pompa
chisciotte le persone cavalcano
necessarie all'entrata
guarda questo quanto ce l'hai khazai
giocatore pensa che abbiamo fatto un
bordello di punti ne normalmente dovremo
consegnare 1 2 massimo 3 tesori nella un
pensa che un tipo da proprio per noi
esatto alla fatto per noi il divo lo ha
fatto per me stessa alla volta del
qualcosa gli ormeggi
abbandonati i pietri chiesto
l'ammissione alla resa per presentare
perché sono calcolati gialloneri tutto
ok
le scorte di capitan bauli e studiata
vai sembra proprio una missione per jack
farlo che nuova app store mino e da
ragazzi all isola forma di cuore come i
capezzoli
eccola barnacle che dobbiamo navigare lì
ti aspetti
fammi vedere nuova fammi vedere anche io
lo penso
ragazzi dovrebbero cavallo questo è
scemo e scemo successo perché perché hai
fatto questa cosa la mia mano verso
spiega mi spieghi perché hai fatto
questa cosa mi lega lo sono perché
ubriaco che sega meteore aerei ubriaco
mi fate ser ubriaco in cinque minuti suo
partito era già briaco maila rateizzo
huskies sono io penserei cavadere mirate
capire la non mi vedo l'importante è
essere bellin enza non è importante
della nona fila sei veramente un film
[Musica]
da palo
la mozzarella 148
quindi siamo rinati napolitano farmaco
sky è quello di arrivare e questa lista
da far mari cuore ti vedeva anche una
tiro ancora non ancora tiriamola ancora
adesso sarà a teramo si chiama le cose
che luccicano melucci che non si vedeva
che la madonna mi sto ma cerca di un
male se sta roba qua vellucci programma
c'è gente o della bottiglia pensavo ma
presto bello ha notato una mappa regala
ragazzi gente occhio c'è un altro cielo
altra nottata l'altra le bottiglie e
messaggi in bottiglia
continua in testamento mimì sembrerà
visto qualcuno era uno schede che lo
scrive tono tranquillo alla ricerca del
sapere nascosto nel tesi ma il cielo per
installarsi prima cerchiamo una prima
cerca trova a sud sudovest praga non lo
sto trovando siamo sicuri che vicino a
st roccia dove caricati per cavolo è
forse scoperto la nuova piazza
ve l'ho detto qualcuno ce l'ha rubata
[Musica]